all right what do the packers need to do
to be the ones who are singing goodbye
to 49ers fans or fans of another team
next year or at some year after that and
getting to the super bowl again well the
big thing is mike and this is no
surprise you've been watching football
all year you watched on sunday the
packers need to improve their interior
defensive line that is like the where it
starts to me it really is you know they
were so compromised in certain games
because they had to unprec
protect their their interior defensive
line that it makes them play some
defensive fronts that weren't
necessarily comfortable to them and
that's what happened in this game mike
they were protecting the interior
defensive line playing a lot of bear
front trying to squash people into the
middle of the line of scrimmage versus
the san francisco 49ers well kyle
shanahan said fine smash yourselves in
there i'm gonna block down we're gonna
toss it outside and we're gonna just
seal everybody off and run all these
outside runs so that's where it has to
start and then after that they need
another weapon on offense that would be
the two things i look at more than
anything more depth and size on the d
line and another explosive weapon to
make people fearful on that offensive
side of the ball and i think they're
right back in the mix of things again
next year
yeah and and i agree with you completely
the question is do they target the draft
do they look to free and see who's
available who may be cut if they trade
for somebody the fact that they have a
general manager in brian gudekunst who
is willing to do something more than
draft and develop draft and develop
draft and develop opens the universe of
possibilities and one of the things
aaron rodgers did after the game on
sunday rattled off the names of the guys
that gouda kunst has brought in who have
become leaders so there's going to be
guys that rogers very much likes to keep
around but there are going to be some
new guys that they'll bring in the team
will look very different and you know at
a certain point yes you have to worry
about competing with the teams in your
division because you play them twice per
year but the 49ers are going to be that
gold standard in the nfc i think for
years to come that's the team that
you're trying to get past right it was
49ers cowboys for four or five years in
the 90s uh it's going to be somebody
49ers and maybe to be a different team
every year but i feel like the 49ers are
going to be in that mix every year if
you want to get to the super bowl at
some point you're going to have to get
past that yeah you're right i mean it
looks that way certainly they're set up
for it and then that goes back right to
what we just talked about i mean the
49ers we've been talking about the whole
show jimmy garoppolo he you know we
don't have to depend on him to win the
game what are you going to do when you
play the 49ers the first thing you got
to do is win the battle up front their
defensive line overwhelms people like
they did at the packers o line during
the game the other day and their
offensive line along with the shanahan
rum scheme overwhelms people too so
that's the first battle you gotta try to
win and that's where green bay's gotta
get better they really gotta get that
the some difference makers on the
interior part you got the smith guys on
the outside they're awesome need more
depth more bodies mike they don't even
have enough depth to where there was
moments in that game where they were
playing nickel and dime defense because
they didn't have enough backup d lyman
to come in so they had to like go
smaller even though the team was running
on them but they had no other way to
arrest some of these guys and that was a
big issue for them in general uh but i
look at that you know we see what they
do with brian balaga right tackle
that'll be another interesting one as
well
this is an offshoot of something chris
you and i were texting about last night
as it relates to the construction of the
49ers roster yeah i think there will be
a premium in this free agency period and
draft for other nfc teams to find
roughneck badass defensive players who
don't need to practice tackling to the
ground who don't need to have the kind
of padded practices that the nfl used to
have you want guys who will go out there
week one with limited preparation
because the current rules make it harder
to get guys physically ready you want
guys who were born ready to go out there
and make that tackle throw themselves in
the path of the of the blocker of the
ball carrier and do the dirty work you
find those guys that's how you slow down
the 49ers running game because i don't
think there's enough of those guys to go
around right now you're right they've
got no hesitation guys guys that'll just
run through the wall coach said do it
we'll do it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports